we shall see shells by the seashore
Peter Piper's banana mum I'd land loudly
I Bradl just had a little bling bless my
little little buddy little ho
mama mia mama mama mama mama mimi mama
mama mama mama mimi mommy mommy mommy
mommy mommy mommy mommy mommy mommy
mommy mommy
hello hello hello everybody hello
everybody hello everybody my name is
markiplier markiplier my name is
markiplier Mario markiplier right
Margalo my everybody look my name is
rocket Lord my lord market like my
grandma's gnomes are loose grandmas
gnomes are loose
Oh
hello hello hello hello hello hello hi
hello hi hello hi hello hello hi hello
hey hi ru hey ha ha ha ha he thrusts his
fists against the posts and still
insists he sees ghosts rubber baby buggy
bumpers rubber baby buggy bugs rubber
baby butt [ __ ] rubber baby buggy bunkers
Rick [ __ ] rubber baby buggy bumpers
rubber baby buggy bumpers rubber baby
buggy bumpers rubber baby buggy [ __ ]
imagine an imaginary menagerie manager
managing an imaginary menagerie
hmm ABCD efg hijk LMNOP QRS TUV wxy Z
ABCD efg hijk LMNOP qrs tuv wxyzi LGD of
gog can one three five seven nine two
four six eight ten 1 3 5 7 9 11 13 15 17
19 20 18 16 14 12 10 eight six four two
zero hello my name is markiplier hello
my name is markiplier hello everybody my
name is markiplier markiplier marke
marke marke Blair hello everybody my
name is markiplier hello
penis doing these poopy popper pants
penis poopy popper pants rubber baby
buggy bluff rubber baby buggy bumpers
rubber baby buggy bumpers rubber baby
buggy bumpers rubber baby buggy bumpers
I could have been an engineer hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to let's play [ __ ]